Ende der Krisensitzung der
Bundesregierung Kabinettsklausur zur
tiefen Energiekrise Kanzler Scholz und
alle Minister zwei Tage lang haben die
die Köpfe zusammengesteckt und was ist
jetzt rausgekommen zum Beispiel bei der
Frage der Atomkraft
Entlastungspaket gasumlage so viele
große Fragen und das sagt der Kanzler
alles zusammengefasst heißt wir haben
die wichtigen Themen der Sicherheit
besprochen was Energie was äußere
Sicherheit betrifft wir haben
Zukunftsfragen besprochen und wir haben
das in einer guten und sehr
konstruktiven Atmosphäre miteinander
getan und auch gewissermaßen hier noch
einmal die Gelegenheit genutzt
unterzuhaken damit wir als Regierung die
wichtigen Entscheidungen vorbereiten und
treffen können die jetzt anstehen damit
es für alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger eine
gute Entwicklung gibt in der es
schwierigen Zeit in der wir uns jetzt
wegen des russischen Angriffskrieges
befinden
richtig eine gute Entwicklung die
wünschen wir uns alle doch man muss die
Frage stellen was kam jetzt dabei raus
zwei Tage Klausur besprechen wir jetzt
mit Jan Schäfer unser politikchef hier
bei uns im Studio ja sind schöne Worte
was steht dahinter ja Olaf Scholz hat es
ja gerade eben gesagt man hat viele
Themen besprochen und genauso ist es
viel besprochen aber wir wissen es gibt
einfach noch zu wenig Ergebnisse
deswegen gerade beim Thema
Entlastungspaket ist die Ampelkoalition
weiter zerstritten in einigen Punkten
Stichwort Bürgergeld Hartz IV und auch
beim Thema Steuern beispielsweise es ist
nicht zu erwarten aus unserer Sicht dass
da in den nächsten zwei drei Wochen
eigentlich ein richtiger durchsprung
Durchbruch kommt von daher war das was
hier passiert in Meseberg einfach mehr
atmosphärisch man hat versucht sie
anzunähern die Probleme bleiben die
gleichen viel gesprochen nichts
entschieden wir können noch mal
reinhören gerade das ging ja über eine
halbe Stunde die die da gesprochen haben
gerade vor der Presse auch also der
Kanzler der Wirtschaftsminister also
Vizekanzler Robert Habeck und dann noch
Christian Lindner der Finanzminister und
man hatte den Eindruck dass es nicht nur
keine Antworten gibt auf die ganz großen
Fragen sondern dass sich der Kanzler
auch ein bisschen Spaß draus macht das
ist keine Antworten gibt schauen wir mal
Jan was er auf die ja Detailfragen zu
einem Entlastungspaket dass er längst
versprochen hat geantwortet hat
kann nicht so viel mitbekommen haben
macht mich professionell stolz
das werden sie dann auch rechtzeitig
mitkriegen auch das möchte ich mit
asianne Klarheit sagen er macht sich ein
Spaß draus dass man überhaupt nicht mal
reingucken kann in das Entlastungspaket
das Paket dass er seit Wochen groß
ankündigt auf dem Marktplätzen da lacht
darüber wenn man fragt was ist drin ja
das ist eine Kommunikationsstrategie die
muss Olaf Scholz den Bürgern wirklich
erklären und ich kann mir auch nicht
vorstellen dass dieser arroganzanfall
das muss man einfach so nennen auch bei
vielen Bürgern ankommt die dich wissen
wie sie am Ende des Monats mit ihren
finanziellen Mitteln immer die Runden
kommen sollen weil sie die einfach nicht
mehr haben also von einem Regierungschef
kann man schon erwarten dass er ganz
klar sagt zu wann etwas geplant ist vor
allem nach so einer Klausur seine
Aussage zeigt aber auch dass einfach
vieles vieles noch völlig ungeklärt ist
das außerdem versucht dass man ja
atmosphärisch in der Ampel wieder
einigermaßen zueinander findet einfach
Olaf Scholz und der Rest seiner
Regierung bisher mit blanken Händen da
steht man ist nicht zusammengekommen die
Kernfragen die strittigen Themen Thema
Steuern Hartz IV Bürgergeld ich habe
schon genannt sind weiterhin offen und
es wird noch einige Zeit dauern bis man
die lösen wird Zeit die auch Geld
bedeutet besonders im ganz konkreten
Fall jetzt in dieser Krise für alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dabei wurde es ja
ja ein groß angekündigt und immer wieder
das Lieblingswort des Kanzlers Zeiten
Wände ja bei seiner Rede haben wir das
gehört dann gab es sehr viel mehr Geld
für die Bundeswehr und dennoch erwartet
man sich von einer Zeitenwende noch
etwas mehr vor allem jetzt wo es für
viele BürgerInnen Bürger im Geldbeutel
ganz schlechte ausschaut schauen wir
einmal rein was der Kanzler sagt zum
Thema Zeitenwende sie werden bemerken
ganz klar sein Lieblingswort in der
letzten Zeit geworden
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
ist eine seitenwende welche Konsequenzen
sich aus der zeitenwände für Europa
folgt aus der Zeitenwende wiederhole
noch mal was ich gesagt habe das ist
eine Zeitenwende er sein Lieblingswort
sehr früh von einer Zeitenwende
gesprochen
man hat mit politikchef Jan Schäfer bei
uns im Studio das Gefühl das ist
natürlich ein tolles Wort das im Februar
dieses Jahres zum ersten Mal kam und bis
heute weiß Olaf Scholz irgendwie selber
nicht ganz genau was dahinter steckt was
eigentlich diese Zeitenwende ausmacht
oder ja Olaf scholzbus erheblich
aufpassen dass dieses Wort zeitenwände
was am 27 februar für eine neue Ära
eigentlich stand auch in der
Bundespolitik Stichwort Rüstung und
überhaupt Ausrüstung Sicherheitspolitik
dass das nicht zu einem wirklichen
leeren Floskel wird zu einer Hülse über
die man sich am Ende des Jahres lustig
macht das Zeiten sich für ein Wort steht
nach dem Motto ich sag mal was aber leg
mich dann schlafen da besteht jetzt die
große Gefahr und auch heute dieses Wort
noch einmal zu benutzen und dann sich
eigentlich der Bevölkerung mit leeren
Händen zu präsentieren das ist kurz
davor lächerlich zu werden mit dem
Wahlkampf war es das Wort Respekt und
jetzt ist es das Wort zeitenwände wir
werden dem Kanzler da weiterhin ganz
genau auf die Finger schauen was er aus
diesen Worten macht Jan Schäfer vielen
Dank für dein Besuch hier im Studio
[Musik]